I don't know about you but I'm not
sleeping beauty
I can't wait a whole century yeah in it
would take a hundred and seventeen years
at the current rate of change for men
and women to earn the same leg well dad
solarian los expertos experts say things
are changing we just have to be patient
[Music]
there are two main reasons why women are
in less than men
number one they pick lower paying work
by older m18 a second they interrupt
their careers first to take care of
their kids and later their parents how
to change this vicious circle
Stephenie sure may be able to help me
she's the president of the Association
of German women entrepreneurs
[Music]
150 men women here in Germany earned 21
percent less than men on average are we
women to blame to some extent if we pick
the wrong professions
I think we need a different perspective
on this issue we need to make
professions like caregiver or elementary
school teacher more attractive to men
but that would lead to higher pay for
such jobs they're being entrusted with
our greatest asset our children and that
should have a higher status women often
reduce their hours or give up working to
take care of their children and later
their parents shouldn't government's
create infrastructure that allows women
to focus on their careers the way men do
course that's very important we will
have a right to daycare or all-day
schooling for our kids but not until
2025 we're discussing this now and we
needed this ten years ago do employers
roll out a woman who's around thirty
years old because she might take
parental leave of course no one has
spared that as an employer and say we
have equal opportunity in Germany when
we stopped looking at a CV from the
viewpoint of will this person take leave
when they have kids if you're interested
in them long term then you'll just see
that as a phase and then you can
overlook it and really focus on their
qualifications and then we're where we
want to be we are miles away from that
so I'm constantly home you my name's
Austin
Dunn's in fear anger calm doesn't be an
off my opponent found ok the politicians
have to act but so do we choose better
paying professions build up your own
business aim higher must don't think I
want to be the best employee think I
want to run the company
so no see that was the way we can make
things change without waiting a hundred
years
[Music]
you